hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge der minecraft facts heute am
samstag ich hatte da gestern leider
keine zeit zu weil ich gelernt habe für
klausuren und so weiter und so fort
allerdings habe ich ja auch schon bei
twitter angekündigt dass diese heutige
folge der minecraft ein wenig anders
sein wird die folge nämlich heute ist
mir persönlich sehr wichtig möchte euch
das eigentlich lieber am ende des videos
sagen damit ich euch das erst quasi in
dem video zeigen kann was genau ich
meine das heißt ihr werdet jetzt das
intro sehen und danach werdet ihr quasi
eine etwas andere minecraft ex folge
sehen ihr werdet natürlich fünf acts
vorgestellt bekommen
allerdings wird das ganze mal ein
bisschen anders ablaufen und danach
werde ich meine persönliche meinung zu
dieser folge sagen und zu den
kommentaren unter einigen folgen und
allgemein so ein paar dinge die ich
loswerden möchte aber ich bitte euch
nicht bis zum ende vor zu spüren
natürlich könnt ihr euch das machen wenn
ihr euch nur für das fazit was ich
daraus schließe interessiert oder so ich
werde defekts auf jeden fall heute ein
bisschen anders vorstellen und wenn ihr
euch das quasi anschaut versteht ihr
denke ich auch am ende was ich mit
dieser folge bewirken möchte deswegen
würde ich sagen sie jetzt das intro land
fangen wir ganz normal an
mit den mai kräftig
erstes ich setze hier einen creeper
hingebe in den chat einsammeln lightning
bolt dann seht ihr schon der wird zu
einem ganz normalen geladenen creeper
und da sehen wir auch schon den ersten
fact ich kann durch die partikel des
kriegers hindurch gucken
ich kann damit quasi durch das wasser
sehen so ein wenig x-ray benutzen mehr
oder weniger x-ray und damit quasi durch
diesen blogs wassers durchschauen und
genau sehen wie der kiste aussieht wie
die erde der aussieht wie der sander
aussieht und so weiter und das perfekt
nummer 1 pick nummer zwei hat auch schon
gleich was mit diesen kritikern hier zu
tun und zwar wenn ich so einen keeper
mit einem unsichtbarkeit trank abwerfe
verschwindet zwar der krieg allerdings
bleiben die partikel hier das könnt ihr
auch hier mal sehen die partikel bleiben
da und wenn ich diesen ganz normalen
prima damit abwehr für seht ihr der
körper verschwindet allerdings bleiben
die partikel da warum das so ist weiß
ich nicht genau aber dass es auf jeden
fall erstmal weg nummer zwei so freunde
der dritte effekt ist wahrscheinlich
kennt schon einige aber wenn ich hier
beispielsweise ein schild dran ansätze
oder auch hier oben hat als beispiel
und jetzt versuche das portal anzuzünden
dann kann ich das nicht anzünden weil
hält hier diese schilder im weg sind
wenn ich allerdings rahmen dahin
platziere beispielsweise mal hier und so
weiter dann setze ich jemand rein auch
zum beispiel oder ihren porzellan
sternchen und zünde ich jetzt das portal
anderen funktioniert das ganze in das
portal geht quasi durch diese rahmen
hindurch das war fekter über 3 und wir
machen direkt weiter mit fake nummer
vier act nummer vier ist dass man pfeile
auch durch fallenden sand durch schießen
kann ich habe hier einen dispenser der
abwechselnd pfeile schießt wenn ich
diesen schalter drückt und ich habe hier
einen schalter der dieses diesen sand
runterfallen lässt jetzt mache ich das
hier beispielsweise mal so und schieße
hier die ganze weile durch und ihr seht
schon ich kann da zwar viele ab und zu
durch schießen das seht ihr
beispielsweise datenkarten fall durch
geflogen jetzt da es auch im fall durch
geflogen jetzt ist der sand auch schon
leer
allerdings geht das nicht immer sondern
ich kann quasi nur viele durchschießen
wirklich immer wenn da gerade mal eine
lücke zwischen den sand dingen sind die
da gerade runter fallen wo freunde wir
haben hier als fünfter fact hier einmal
so eine kleine arena mehr oder weniger
aufgebaut ich setze hier mal einen
dorfbewohner hin und hier einen zombie
und es ist ja klar der zombie geht
direkt auf den dorfbewohner los bis er
ihn töten wird und er geht dabei auch
ganz normal über den teppich darüber
wenn ich mir das allerdings wieder mal
anschaue da ist nichts drunter
hier sind allerdings noch teppiche
drunter und wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise mit einem teppich nehme
und hier einfach ein paar teppiche
beieinander hinsetze ist der effekt auch
damit schon quasi gesagt und zwar 2
ist er ihn komplett durch auf mehreren
teppichen übereinander wenn die da drauf
stehen
das heißt wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
die beiden hier einfach mal töten würde
wenn ihr das jetzt mal seht her ich töte
jetzt erst mal den einen zombie dann
töte ich hier noch dem villiger jetzt
mache ich das hier ganz immer wieder zu
und wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise mehr
hier in manager hinsetze und hier ein
zombie seht ihr schon der zombie läuft
natürlich auf den villiger zu aber er
dreht sich dabei immer so ganz komisch
im kreis ich weiß nicht woran das liegt
es ist auf jeden fall fake nummer 500
tritt nur ein wirklich wenn der mehrere
teppich ebenen übereinander sind wenn da
steht macht es wieder nichts aber wenn
er gleich wieder in bewegung kommt wird
er sich wieder so bestehen und dass es
fake nummer fünf freunde des rates mit
dieser folge der minecraft heute am
samstag ich nehme zwar gerade am freitag
auf am freitagabend aber ich habe eine
klausur geschrieben alles möglich und
möchte heute abend nicht mehr um 11 uhr
es ist gerade noch hochladen
ich habs auf twitter ja wie gesagt schon
angekündigt dass die folge heute ein
bisschen anders wird ihr habt natürlich
wie immer euro 5 acts bekommen aber
gerade darüber möchte ich mit euch reden
und zwar diese effect serie ist eine
serie die habe ich damals angefangen
weil ich lust hatte euch facts
vorzustellen in minecraft wenn ich das
selber interesse daran hatte ich habe da
immer noch interesse daran neue sachen
dazu zu lernen deswegen habe ich ja
beispielsweise auch diese command serie
gemacht deswegen stelle ich auch öfters
mal mods vor weil es einfach cool finde
und interessant finde wenn so total
abgefuckte sachen vorgestellt werden wir
sehen also was wissenswertes oder
unnützes wissen er sind ja diese facts
und so weiter und so fort finde ich
einfach ganz cool und das gefällt mir
auch so was dann vorzustellen
aber was mir jetzt halt einfach
aufgefallen ist dass diese fake serie
wirklich komplett nur auf die facts
beschränkt wird habe nämlich in letzter
zeit einfach mal so ein bisschen die
kommentare beobachtet und dabei ist mir
quasi aufgefallen dass viele leute
wirklich schreiben hey was soll das das
ist eine fact serie wie so redest du
vorher zwei minuten über dein leben du
hast uns mitte defekt zu zeigen doch
gerade mal einfach einen schönen
kommentar ausgesucht der das ganze ganz
gut wiedergibt und zwar schreibt mister
unbekannt ich möchte keine namen nennen
ich finde es blöd wie du immer behindert
oder spastisch sagst und brauchst über
zwei minuten bis der erste fakt kommt
kurz gesagt kein vorbild und langweilig
ist meine meinung und soll kein held
sein finde es schade dass du so geworden
bist
dazu möchte ich mach erst mal einfach so
dass wir uns jetzt hier so ein bisschen
dass ich ihr hier nicht die ganze zeit
zu minecraft sachen sehen müsst also ich
mach mal eben kurz vor jetzt sind wir
wieder hier ganz normal dass ich jetzt
mal so mit euch reden kann und zwar
diesen kommentar habe ich ausgesucht ich
möchte da wie gesagt nicht die person
veranstalten die den geschrieben hat
deswegen bin ich auch keinen namen aber
sie schreibt ich finde es blöd wie du
immer behindert oder spastischer sagst
und brauchst über zwei minuten ist der
erste weg kommt kurz gesagt kein vorbild
und langweilig ich meine das müsst ihr
selber sehen ob ich eine vorbildfunktion
darstelle oder ob ich das nicht mache
oder ob meine videos langweilig sind
oder nicht aber wenn jemand sich darüber
beschwert dass ich nicht zwei minuten
vom video lagern soll dann ist es
natürlich in einer gewissen form
konstruktive kritik und ich sollte mich
daran halten
aber in einer gewissen form fühle ich
mich einfach wie eine maschine weiß
nicht ob ihr das nachvollziehen könnt
aber ich gehe hier hin nach hause nehmen
ein video auf zum beispiel dann mal
minecraft folge die g2 sieben bis zwölf
minuten immer so um den dreh und da rede
ich dann halt auch ein bisschen über
mich weil mich einige leute immer so
fragen hey wie ließ denn irgendwie mit
den klausuren oder wie war dein dies
oder hey luca was ist denn deine meinung
dazu und so und da lasse ich mich dann
auch gern mal davon ablenken und ich bin
halt auch nur ein mensch möchte mit euch
kontakt haben sonst würde ich youtube ja
nicht machen und deswegen rede ich da
halt manchmal drüber und dann sehe ich
allerdings in den kommentaren einfach
beiträge von nutzern mit ihren anonymen
internet nahmen die denken ja im
internet sieht mich ja keiner und so hey
das ist also das weiß nicht auf diesen
kommentar bezogen hab ich habe schon
andere kommentare gesehen wo man
beleidige wo ich beleidigt wurde
weil ich nicht direkt auf den punkt
gekommen weil ich nicht direkt am anfang
des videos gesagt habe ja hallo hier ist
fällt nummer eins fällt über 243 445
video in einer minute abgehakt und
einfach nur auf eine aufnahme button
gedrückt ich bin jemand der videos macht
weil mir das video machen spaß macht und
was wir noch viel mehr spaß macht es die
nachbearbeitung das hat man glaube ich
in einigen letzten videos gesehen wo ich
dann immer wirklich da wird man die
musik leiser werden wenn ich einen witz
reise oder die kamera zoomt an mich ran
das bin ja alles ich dass das bearbeite
ich ja ich sitze bei der video
vorbereitung eine halbe stunde und beim
bearbeiten ein bis zwei stunden weil mir
das einfach mega viel spaß macht und
deswegen finde ich dass diese folgen das
an meine videos quasi finde ich dass ich
das da durch diese bearbeitung schaffe
meine videos so ein bisschen
menschlicher zu machen also wenn ich
wenn ich wirklich das hört sich komisch
an aber wenn ich von mir ein video sehen
würde wenn ich jemanden sehen würde der
einfach wirklich wie eine maschine
rackert und da steht im titel fünfmal
kraftwerks und einzige was er macht ist
er stellt euch fünf micro facts fordert
dass das könnte ich mir nicht anschauen
das ist natürlich nur meine meinung und
viele teilen die meinung wahrscheinlich
auch nicht aber was ich möchte ist dass
da jemand sitzt der mir auch ein
bisschen was über sich preisgibt er auch
so ein bisschen unterhaltung damit rein
bringt deswegen ist diese minecraft
serie serie durch relativ viel
bearbeitet dann hat die person die
diesen kommentar verfasst hat wieder
geschrieben gut da sind es noch menschen
wie dich gibt es ist ja meine meinung
ich werde wetten die die rumheulen
hassen die terroristen die charlie hebdo
getötet haben wie ich aber watson rum
weil ich auch meinungsfreiheit äußere
aber egal
freunde ich weiß das internet ist ein
ist ein als ein massenmedium dass das
web 2.0 was die interaktion der menschen
untereinander anregt und auch ein
bisschen als als zielsetzung hat aber
ich manchmal natürlich kann man sich ein
anonym schaffen und im internet
kommentare posten aber wenn ich sowas
lese unter meinen videos dann klatsche
ich mir sowas von die hand ins gesicht
das ganze hier soll jetzt kein video
sein wo ich jetzt irgend jemanden in den
kommentaren auseinander rufen möchte ich
habe den kommentarschreiber ja nicht mal
erwähnt oder so weil ich einfach nicht
möchte dass eine hält welle los tritt
ich möchte einfach nur mal sagen was was
derzeit auf youtube los ist finde ich
überhaupt nicht richte youtuber werden
als maschinen angesehen ich habe einfach
dieses zwei stunden video von grond mehr
angeschaut wo er das auch richtig gut
behandelt hat also wenn ihr im aufguss
kanal geht sein sein jahres special da
zum jahr 2015 ist echt empfehlenswert wo
gerade das nochmal gesagt wird youtuber
werden dargestellt als die neuen stars
die neuen ikonen hey wir müssen da in
das magazin und wir müssen da auf eine
messe und hier so viele leute und da
soviel publicity das ist doch einfach
schwachsinn wir sind einfach nur
menschen
wir sind keine maschinen wie ich wenn
mir jemand in den kommentaren sagt hey
beim nächsten mal hörst du mal bitte auf
über dein privatleben zu reden und kommt
direkt auf den punkt
selbst uns die sachen davor nein das bin
ich nicht ich bin keine maschine die die
ganze zeit liefert ich bin jemand der
mit euch hinter agieren möchte der
kommunikation sucht und der einfach
nicht dass ich möchte mir nicht befehl
lassen was ich zu tun habe und was ich
zu lassen habe auf youtube das tolle auf
youtube ist und deswegen habe ich
angefangen dass ich mir selbst aussuchen
kann wie viel ich hochladen dass ich
sagen kann diese facts folge kommt nicht
am freitag sondern die kommt am samstag
und von mir aus rede ich jetzt noch zehn
minuten darüber wie blöd ich das einfach
derzeit hier alles finde das kann ich
bei youtube und ich finde es traurig
dass darüber hergezogen wird das youtube
angesagt wird hey mach mal dies hey mach
mal dass sie die die und die person ist
einer zeitschrift oggi und die person
etwas macht über alles wird geredet die
über jeden jeder wird kritisiert aber
die wahre eigenschaft von youtube geht
quasi verloren noch mal kurz auf den
kommentar zurückzukommen um einfach nur
damit ich euch sage warum ich diesen
kommentar aus genommen habe
das ist einerseits in dem ersten
kommentar den er geschrieben hat geht er
mich selber an und natürlich es ist von
ihnen aus gesagt kein held deswegen
werde ich das auch nicht als held
dastehen lassen aber wenn man mir sagt
ja mach mal diesmal das ist es einfach
keine konstruktive kritik sondern es ist
einfach hey das ist du bist für mich
kein vorbild mehr
du stellst uns nicht direkt die facts
vor so von wegen hague nächstes mal
machst du im video vielleicht einfach
gar nichts du zeigst nur minecraft die
infect du redest einer anderen sachen du
lachst nicht du stellst uns einfach
direkt vor ort ein anderes beispiel was
mich echt da habe ich wirklich eine
halbe stunde darüber nachgedacht was
denn falsch gelaufen ist und zwar
schreibt dort jemand hey conny als ich
auf dem server von meinem freund gezockt
habe ist mir folgendes aufgefallen wenn
man im hellen portal steht kann man sein
inventar nicht öffnen
denk ich mir es mag es ein ganz normaler
kommentar mit ganz normalen fact und so
und dann kommt ein anderer nutzer
darunter ich möchte wie immer keine
namen nennen und er mein bordeaux opfer
das weiß jeder halt dein maul und stirbt
ich weiß nicht was ich da sagen soll ob
das üble nachrede ist oder schon rufmord
oder einfach unter cyber bullying oder
oder als cyber mobbing wird glaube ich
mittlerweile sogar genannt ob das
darunter zu fassen ist das müsste man
juristisch irgendwie das ich will ich
will damit auch gar nicht jetzt
irgendwas machen oder so sondern einfach
dieses verhalten unter
einander das ist gerade der cea siebte
anlauf dass sich dieses video aufnehmen
es ist jetzt fast schon wieder mitten in
der nacht und ich lass das jetzt so
einfach drin ich habe vorhin auch schon
irgendwie 30 minuten aufgenommen ist bin
ich auch schon nach halber 27 minuten
einfach ein kurzer abschluss zu dieser
folge war die folge jetzt wichtig war
ich habe die facts folge heute so
gestaltet wie dieser nutzer den
kommentar den ich vorgelesen hatte wo
ich wirklich nichts gegen den nutzer
habe außer dass das er halt meinte ja
nächstes mal erzählt sie mal bitte nicht
so bei deinem privatleben duett nicht
zwei minuten vorher sondern du fängst
verbietet direkt an mit dem effekt so
habe ich heute das video gestaltet ich
habe keine witze gemacht ich habe die
musik durchgespielt ich habe keine
einblendungen zwischendurch gemacht ich
hab mich nicht ran gesund in face käm
ich hab nicht gedacht ich hab keine
witze gerissen ich habe keine lustige
szenen eingeblendet nicht die musik
teilweise gestoppt oder irgendwas
anderes witziges gemacht oder sowas in
verbindung zu den fans stand nein ich
habe euch heute wirklich einfach nur
defekts vorgestellt und einfach sonst
nichts daran bearbeitet allerdings muss
ich wirklich sagen es hat mir es fiel
mir so schwer dieses video heute
aufzunehmen weil ich mache nehme defekts
auf und lasse einfach alles drin wenn
irgendwas schief läuft ich lasse drin
weil ich daraus eventuell witzige szene
machen kann und das ist nämlich meine
art videos zu produzieren natürlich gibt
es andere youtuber oder auch allgemein
ganz andere leute die andere vorlieben
haben die sagen dann ja das ist genau
meine art das mag ich wenn ich videos so
mache und die einfach nicht bearbeitet
oder so sondern einfach so in minecraft
sockel vielleicht sagen auch andere hey
ich mag es lieber wenn man es ganz
anders macht so ganz ganz viel
bearbeitet oder so das ist natürlich
jedem selbst überlassen das respektiere
ich auch und das ist genau das was ich
sagen möchte und zwar meine lieblings
methode ist ich nehme das einfach auf
wie es mir gefällt schneide das wie es
mir gefällt und ich lade hoch und wenn
es euch gefällt dann freut mich weil
dann haben wir was gemeinsam was uns
quasi gefällt aber wenn es einem nicht
gefällt dann sollte man es mir zumindest
nicht verbieten und wenn ich dann
kommentare lese wie ja das kann doch
nicht sein nächstes mal erzählt man
nicht zwei minuten vorher oder so
darüber wenn weg oder irgendwie sowas
die nächste mal direkt mit dem weg
sondern denke ich einfach nur sowas soll
das einfach als schlussstrich jetzt
quasi man sollte einander wirklich mit
respekt begegnen und wenn
wenn ich weiß echt nicht wie ich das
sagen soll nun dieser zweite kommentar
den ich auch vorgelesen habe mit diesem
halt dein maul und stirbt oder irgendwie
so ich weiß nicht ich habe mich da nur
daran erinnern dass irgendwann mal bei
n-tv de n24 darüber berichtet wurde dass
ich irgendeine 14 jährige hannah smith
oder irgendwie so erhängt hat aufgrund
von kommentaren im internet war ein paar
leute meinten haye kommen
das was du machst es interessiert keinen
steht doch einfach das wäre besser für
uns alle
da musste ich da irgendwie daran denken
und ich finde einfach vielleicht sagen
auch einige jahr dieser zweite
kommentare mit mit walter moll und
stirbt hat doch gar nichts damit zu tun
dass der erste kommentar meint dass du
nächste mal nicht zwei minuten lagern
soll es vielleicht rege ich mich auch
gerade zu viel auf oder hat zu viel um
die ohren und und bin zu aggressiv das
tut mir leid aber ich möchte wirklich
und es liegt mir schon lange auf dem
herzen einfach mal angesprochen haben
dass ich finde die umgangsweise wie man
untereinander auf youtube mittlerweile
umgeht wie man im internet miteinander
umgeht und was einem als youtuber von
der community von den leuten die youtube
mögen quasi gesagt wird ist nicht mehr
das was youtube ist youtube ist wirklich
das habe ich schon so oft gesagt
broadcast yourself von wegen hier nimm
dich auf das hoch mach was du möchtest
dass es youtube du bist du so
eigenwillig du kannst du's selbständig
kannst machen was du möchtest kannst
hochladen was du möchtest ich würde mich
wirklich freuen dass in denn in zukunft
einfach also ich bin total unzufrieden
jetzt auch schon wieder mit diesem video
aber ich werde jetzt einfach drin lassen
und ich glaube es ist gut dass ich mir
kein skript gemacht habe sondern dass
ich einfach so meine gedanken einfach
mal so gesagt habe
es tut mir leid falls irgendwelche leute
angegangen bin oder ihnen das anders
gemacht habe ich die tonspur ist halt
hier einfach jetzt schon 37 minuten lang
deswegen habe ich nicht mehr genau im
hinterkopf was ich alles genau gesagt
habe aber ich denke die wichtigsten
sachen habe ich gesagt ich möchte
einfach dass man unter einander mit
respekt agiert dass man nicht sagt hey
der effekt wird schon vorgestellt als
marlon b sterben
ich möchte nicht dass man sagt hey luca
im nächsten video machst du aber mal
bitte das und das ich möchte einfach nur
mein ding auf youtube machen und wenn
mir jemand sagt was ich zu tun und zu
lassen habe dann wäre ich damit ganz
ganz unglücklich und wird direkt mit
youtube aufhören und ich möchte nicht
mit youtube auf sondern ich mach das
weiter wie ich das möchte und das
einfach jetzt so als abschluss es tut
mir leid dass sich diese folge darf
jetzt missbrauchen musste aber ich
dachte mir einfach bei den fans habe ich
die kommentare gesehen deswegen macht
das mit effektvoll jetzt einfach mal die
nächsten videos werden wieder vernünftig
kommen ich weiß nicht ob heute noch ein
zweites video kommt oder ob morgen video
kommt oder ob ich erstmal ein bisschen
abstand nehme wegen lernen und klausuren
und so habe ich hoffe ich konnte euch
bitte irgendwie was jetzt sagen was ich
meine ich ja egal